some compounds smell really good because
of the chemicals they contain cinnamon
and vanilla have a pleasant odor that
you might call aromatic when an organic
chemist uses this word they're likely
referring to aromaticity which is a
special feature of some compounds now I
don't want to imply that all molecules
with aromaticity smell good pyridine is
an aromatic compound with an unpleasant
fish-like odor and this aromatic
pyridine salt has no sense at all
additionally compounds that are not
aromatic can have strong odors so if
aromaticity isn't tied to smell how can
we tell if a compound is aromatic let's
begin by talking about benzene the
classical example of an aromatic
compound we can draw a resonance form
for benzene where it looks like the
double bonds have moved but this isn't
the whole story at all there's a
continuous system of P orbitals above
and below the ring the electrons are
actually delocalized around the ring
circling around the PI system an
electron density map of benzene shows
red hot spots of electron density where
the PI electrons are concentrated
although some benzene representations
seem to have alternating single and
double bonds each bond is 1.3 9
angstroms long which is between the
length of a carbon-carbon double and
single bond this is due to the
delocalization of electrons that we
discussed and it makes aromatic
compounds rather stable to be aromatic a
cyclic compound must have a continuous
PI system and be planar it must also
satisfy huckel's rule having 4n plus 2
electrons in the PI system where n is 0
or a small positive number
now compounds that contain 4n electrons
in the PI system are particularly
unstable and are referred to as anti
aromatic we need to be able to identify
aromatic compounds because they have
unique reactivity when an alkene is
treated with bromine the double bond
acts as a nucleophile forming a cation
that is attacked by BR - the end result
is the addition of BR 2 across the
double bond
when benzene is treated with bromine and
iron catalyst is required because of
benzene stability benzene attacks
bromine but br- does not add to the
cation the stability gained by the
compound becoming aromatic again is so
great that the intermediate is
deprotonated instead resulting in the
addition of just one bromine atom let's
explore some more examples of aromatic
compounds when N equals zero there are
two electrons in the PI system and an
example is a cyclopropenyl cation if N
equals one there are six electrons in
the PI system and benzene and pyridine
are examples pyridine is a weak base
because it has a lone pair that does not
participate in the PI system it sticks
out perpendicular or orthogonal to the
PI electrons
orthogonal lone pairs can make bonds
without disrupting aromaticity
so this methyl substituted pyridinium
ion like the pyridine salt we saw
earlier is also aromatic perimeter is
another example it has two orthogonal
lone pairs and three double bonds in the
ring making up the PI system perimeter
rings are very important because they
make up your DNA the cyclopentadienyl
anion is an aromatic five membered ring
the negative charge on carbon is a lone
pair that can participate in the PI
system building on this parole is also
an aromatic compound at first glance it
appears there are only four pi electrons
however there is a lone pair on nitrogen
that can participate in the PI system
Duran is also aromatic because one of
the oxygen lone pairs contributes
geometrically the second lone pair can't
join so we have six PI electrons again
here this positively charged seven
membered ring is also aromatic the carbo
cation is trigonal planar the empty p
orbital occupies the space above and
below the ring making a continuous PI
system
when we get into 10 electron PI systems
things get a little more complicated
psychological penta een that's most of
our criteria for aromaticity it
satisfies huckel's rule and a cyclic
with a continuous PI system however in
order to be flat it would need to have
bond angles of 144 degrees which is far
from the normal bond angle for an sp2
hybridized carbon carbon bond so the
strain overcomes any aromatic
stabilization and this molecule bends ok
so what if we introduce some trans
double bonds to relieve the angle strain
we run into a different problem here
because the H atoms are now facing
inward toward each other they have
steric clash and this molecule is not
planar either but if the H atoms are
replaced with a methylene bridge the
steric hindrance is eliminated and this
molecule is aromatic returning to our
chart this eight membered ring with two
nitrogen atoms is another example of a
tenth high electron aromatic compound
because both nitrogen lone pairs are
needed to complete the PI system they
have to be substituted with electron
donating groups if the groups are too
electron withdrawing the lone pairs are
pulled out of the PI system this
molecule twists because aromatic
stabilization can no longer overcome
steric strain this nine membered ring is
also aromatic again provided that the
nitrogen is substituted with electron
donating groups and can contribute to
the PI system
you